the the other
chapter that you had in this book that
immediately caught my attention
and to be honest this was the very first
i skipped right ahead this is the first
one i read
um it was the the chapter entitled
own a motorcycle and it talks about
masculine therapy
and see this is this is one of the
chapters that i put in there
in intentionally to deviate from the
whole let's keep this busy around women
there's probably at least a third of the
book dedicated to content that has
nothing to do with women
it's got to do with mental point of
origin and yourself and this is also by
the way how i can tell when somebody
leaves like a crap review that they
didn't even read the book they just
bought the book to [ __ ] on it but
whatever
um but yeah the importance of a
motorcycle have you ever owned a
a bike uh no i've i've ridden them but
i've never owned one
my my father's a mechanic so we had them
growing up yeah yeah
yeah um so this this became obvious to
me when i was
starting up my business in the first two
years because we moved into this old
century home
and it was one of those nicely like
renovated 150 year old homes with the
nice touches on the inside sort of [ __ ]
but
we were on the second floor and on the
main floor there was a psychologist that
she was an old frumpy cairn-looking lady
she'd come up every week and yell at us
for making too much noise and then go
back down
but my office sat out on a window
looking into the parking lot
and i think we were i think we were in
that building for about two or three
years so i had
so i had a good two years of of traffic
watch
like walking them come in and out of the
building because all of our business was
basically done on the
done over the phone rarely saw customers
and the one common thing that i noticed
was
most of her customers were women they
all they always had
um pitch resting face so you know brf
whatever the acronym is for that
and when guys showed up they never rode
motorcycles and i
and i was thinking to myself at the time
like when i was younger i used to get on
my bike and solve
every problem that i had you know my
girlfriend cheated on me
i didn't get the promotion at work uh
blah blah
you know insert whatever get on the bike
go for a rep right and that would solve
your problem
you don't need a therapist you don't
need drugs you don't need
antidepressants
all you really need is a young guy as a
bike trust me
and i think there's something about
riding a bike which is almost meditative
because you have to be present
very present you have to have your head
on a swivel somebody said in the
comments there sports cars
uh do they count um i think i wrote at
the end
uh fast convertibles so that's that's
about as close as you can get
so it has to have the top down yeah like
you have to feel
the elements on you like that's one of
the things that you feel on a bike like
if you've ever redlined a sport bike in
sixth gear on the highway
like you'll get up to 280 330 kilometers
an hour which is pretty freaking fast
and wind pressure like all the wind over
your body like you feel it right like
you know that you're out there you know
that you're doing something that most
people can't or won't do
right it's about pushing yourself
basically
yeah pushing yourself uh being
comfortable in a very uncomfortable
situation testing yourself
as well because it requires that it
requires your head had to be on a swivel
a lot a lot of physical awareness a lot
of situational awareness
balance coordination adrenaline rush
yeah
reaction reaction speed like all this
stuff all these like really all these
things that are also very good
to have as a man like situat situational
awareness reaction time
etc all apply there
and it keeps you and like because when
you're in a car like i know like
coming from australia right when we
drive in australia it's just
it's just an endless straight road like
that's
basically roads in australia it's
between towns you're like okay i'm just
going to drive for the next
hour straight and nothing's going to
happen
and that's why we have we actually have
a lot of car fatalities because of that
because people fall asleep at the wheel
because there's nothing to do
but in a car it's like oh music's
playing audiobooks playing or whatever
cruise controls on and you're just
you're not you're zoning out you're on
autopilot
you can't be on autopilot when you're on
a motorbike it's like
you've got all the everything else on
the road is probably going to kill you
because they're not paying attention
so there we have it yeah
sounds like death by a pedal one day at
a time
uh oh and jim jim respectfully disagrees
he says carbureted vx with long tube
headers
and steep gears works for him yeah it's
a nice you know it's a nice uh
fun thing to throw your time and money
at but you still can't touch
again you know you get on a sport bike
you tuck in tight you're doing 330
kilometers an hour
with the rev limiter bouncing off the
[ __ ] you know fuel
fuel cut off that's that's fast that's
you know that's some serious adrenaline
rush and you mentioned something in
there
that uh i thought was quite interesting
the only piece of
dating advice my father ever gave me was
put a girl on a motorbike yeah chick
stick bikes and she'll get
you'll get a panty like put on a
motorbike get her to grab onto you
floor it and right around corners and
she'll be dripping wet by the time you
get it back to your place
i i actually talk about that in the
motorcycle chapter but we won't talk
about the details there because you guys
have to read it
i just found it quite funny i was like
oh damn that's exactly exactly what dad
told me
uh jerry oaksmith with the 25 super chat
thank you very much sir
he says technically bikes can be about
the woman
they have to be fully submissive their
life is in your hands and their hands
are wrapped around
you holding on yeah if you want to talk
about frame you will always
have her in your frame on a motorcycle
guys how do i get her in my frame i
don't understand what frame is what is
it just get a motorcycle and throw a
check on the back she's on she's in your
frame automatically
right right she's not sitting there like
carrying you she's not telling you what
to do and if she is get her off the bike
just just get rid of the check
keep going just pop a wheelie and just
say see you see you guys
[Laughter]
drop her off bang just drop her off at
the next bus stop
keep the helmet just keep it as a
souvenir we'll see you later
oh my god that we saw a ton of that when
i was hanging out with myron gaines in
miami there was we went
went to one particular suburban it was
just tons of dudes like it was a bit of
a
a bit of a dodgy suburb i think but
the clubs were and there's all these
dudes like riding up and down the
[ __ ] strip with it with
on there like dirt on dirt bikes in the
middle of the suburbs
yeah with like with all these big fat
black chicks on the back
it makes it easier to wheel you right
because then you have the extra
counterweight on the back
so that you know it comes up easier so
much
i was wondering what like why on earth
is he putting the fat [ __ ] on there
bro i remember the very first time i put
a
a a bigger woman on the back of my bike
when i was younger
and i was surprised how easily the bike
wheelie when i was on the throttle like
normally you get on the throttle in
first gear on a 600 and it won't wheelie
but with a but with some weight behind
you
all right you've solved this mystery for
me
you know like these these good looking
like you know black dudes like
they're well like good looking in shape
i'm like why is this guy got a fat [ __ ]
on the back of his bike okay
it was because you could it's because
you could do wheelies easily
in front of the cafe where we were and
then sean always used to make sure the
girls wore like the daisy duke
cut off jean shorts where you had cheeks
hanging out oh jesus
man i'm telling you guys bikes they're
cheap they're fast they're
you know women dig them they're they're
a lot of fun they're cheap to ensure
that's dangerous though you got to be
careful though yeah
like the thing i'm there the thing i'm
always
aware of when i'm in here in australia
in america rather is people who ride
around in
in [ __ ] jeans and a t-shirt or in
shorts that was me
dude one thing my dad drilled into me
was like where [ __ ]
letters if you're gonna you're gonna
drive a bike wear leathers for god's
sake because everyone's
cause i had so he had he actually had uh
when i was younger
one of his apprentices at his workshop
got into a motorcycle accident
and he took me and my brother and my
sister to go because we knew the guy
he used to go see him in the hospital
after he got into a motorcycle crash
the mess his [ __ ] skin his legs man
it was just like
he'd been barbecued yeah it was jesus
[ __ ] christ
like leathers help but when it's hot as
hell i was i was always the guy with the
shorts and the helmet and and
that was pretty much it man it was like
it's hot out it's 30 40 degrees with
humidity i'm just i'm just rolling like
this i'm not sweating
[ __ ] it you live once right yeah
you